der achte auflage der offenen
superspiel sexy und ich glaube viel
früher drei jahre nicht begleichen pennt
gehört sondern dass du da bist und das
ist so ungefähr die dicksten
[Musik]
ja heute einmal das immer wieder
flaschenpost mit der barbara und mit mir
schützen thema liebe und zu der frage
kann ich eine person als nur
die 49
stunden
überhaupt
es ist schon komisch
was ist liebe also natürlich wegen ihrer
liebe zum partner dann lebe ich mich hin
denn die anderen unter freunden oder
auch sehr gar nicht was ich mit den
älteren schwester die erste komplette
schwierig
interessant wenn eine
verstärkte partie lieber oder mich da
muss man
fragen zu unterschiedliche qualität
ja aber es könnten aber noch bestand hat
ich habe nur eins ist unsere romantische
liebe nein hier kommt mit sexuellen
bedienen oder ok das wird also es hat
bitte bitte liebe zu zeigen das hofft
unter
den partner herrscht dass es geht ab
reform sexuelle relief sexuellen wünsche
wie
haben sie das bedürfnis noch herum
bezirk also das macht's ganze sei sehr
knifflig denn
dafür dass die geschichte also
unterscheidet zwischen eros das wäre die
erotische liebe romantische lebemann und
das körper die körperliche intimität
gesucht wird das andere vielleicht die
akp wird das erkennt wird so eine
göttliche selbstlose liebe zum ring
gegenüber schon gleich nur geht und so
genau und viele jahre freundschaft oder
software
spezialisten
aber trocken sich damit ihr die der
erosion erotisch romantische idee ein
partnerschaftlicher liche politischen
auftrag wieso
das im moment sehr im trend liegen
selbst vor der polyamorie
was nicht heißt offene beziehung also
keine beziehung mit ihrer partnerin aber
schlaf ab und zu mit der anderen sondern
ich lieber nicht nur mini partnerin
sondern ich lieber auf eine romantische
und
dass wenn die philosophische sehr
interessantes konzept
ich glaube wer steckt und wie sehr
ist das harz ist durchtränkt ist mit
normen und erwartete un konvention auf
unsere gesellschaft mit dem romantisch
erzielte jedem dorf oder spielfilm
gesamte jedem buch sieht nachlesen gibt
es immer zwei oder irgendein stattfindet
und dass aldi durch die hand so ist es
dankend ist das herz dass es zu
schwierig ist
weil ich so hat die wahre form verlieren
wenn ich eine andere freiheit live
player da falls ich das bedürfnis zahlen
was spricht dagegen und der empfehler
allgemein tvi verachtung zu
widerstand mit einem bliebe karl jenkins
das schon philosophin wo viel publiziert
zum thema polyamorie war polyamid und
sie seit genau da müssen wir sind
eigentlich
normativ also wir sind durch trank mit
normativität
normal ist norm ist dass man ein partner
ein portier unserer gesellschaft es geht
ja politik gesellschaft aber die äußere
gesellschaftliches ideal und allenfalls
eröffnet mit den betroffenen geht also
weiter springt zur oder einfach so
andere liebschaften
aber es bleibt eine romantische zweier
kiste und pauli am ries
normativität muskel und sagen es gibt
eine vielfalt von lebensformen und
kollaboriert genau gleich gut und es
gibt nicht so der
alleinstellungsmerkmal von dem einen
partner oder eine partnerin womit jeder
mit ihm die zweite stütze nochmals auf
stufe
ich glaube ich ganz vorne zu bewerten
interessant finde also ich muss sagen
ich komme ich zur sprache wie lasse ich
lese ich habe das aber nicht aber
interessant finde wenn die chance dass
die sagen du hast dich gar nicht so sehr
für das entscheide das stößt geben die
einfach zu die von murat die hand das
ideal für sich findet für sie ist es
besser und dafür beziehen sie hat aber
sie damit sagen alles andere macht der
sport sei das ist kein scherz sondern es
ist das was irgendwie
entspricht und wird es interessant wäre
ich glaube ganz viele tänze moment wo
sie sich zu anderem die zuckertüten
täglichen entscheidungsspiel mit mietet
man die person schützen 60
lebt man sicherlich das darf doch nicht
sie unterdrückt mal aufgeführt ich
glaube dass kenne ganz viel also liebe
ich auch immer ein kompromiss zwischen
der geborgenheit der verschmelzung mit
der freiheit und gleichzeitig deren
kitzel und der intensität und denn der
neugier oder
und und das glaube ich ich begrüße
manager stärker ausprägt und bei anderen
weniger und wenn das stark da ist das
zweite element der finde ich das musste
ich mich erinnere
er ist bis an die an die vom rat aber
das ist interessant dass das also quasi
man fühlt sich zu öffnen mcnish
twitter-suche und haben das entweder
einfach feststellen und plötzlich
berühmt ist das wieder beruhigt oder das
nähre
für das keine rolle und wenn vc-sprecher
verloren und wenn man das nicht macht
dann kann das unterschiedliche gründe
nicht eigentlich ein diese enorm ich
darf das nicht aber das andere fängt ja
sie das ist ihr system commitment zu den
personen und damit
committer zu öffnen das hätte so ri
bisherige büro des eigentlichen wert
wohl zu einfach nicht für mich ich würde
nicht sagen dass roger moore laden die
menschen irgendwie nicht auf commitment
und verlässlichkeit sondern einfach
immer noch einmal gesperrt ist das ist
so wie das schicksal großer war
commitment aber du musst nur mit einer
person hat branche wirklich die
exklusivität die ausschließlichkeit
woher und das eigentlich muss das so sie
uns zeit und ich etwas nicht damit
besitzt dank hits tour
nach kontrolle und setzte wenig
vertrauen und sowitec dann darf dann
immer noch vor allzu lange du könntest
du verlierst im verlustangst motor sein
dafür
stehen so wichtig wenn du ihnen erlaubt
regulierbar wo geht es gut und ich
wirklich sehr beeindruckt von der sehr
jungen autorin die heißt ann-christin
klufti des buches heißt es und das ist
herr minister kritik
von deinen neues verhalten ist und
fehlende neue formel im ratsaal arbeit
und sie beschrieb das phänomen wo sie
seit es gibt oft iqdoq sogenannten
vanilla cherry und das ist eigentlich da
glüht wo so der kuschel sex als idealer
presets und wo wir zeigen mit mit dem
partner oder der partnerin und so die
romantische zwei kisten schön findet und
vanilla 66 ist eigentlich eine passive
vanilla 6 bevor gestern und das vanilla
cherry meint genau dass du musst behält
anders unterwegs sie was ja irgendwie
das
endspiel ist und die shades of trade und
krasse sachen offene beziehung
[Musik]
andere spieler passt und so dass ich
genau ist student krieg sondern das sind
neu geschaffen wurde und zwar sehr oft
so zumindest die these von ihrer frau
stoff der frau eine partnerin wird tagen
verliert und ganz ehrlich ich liebe dich
immer noch genauso wird das ist ob das
ist nicht so ich empfinde mich fertig
und ist vielleicht nicht sondern ich
lieb dich noch genauso
wenig dass diese kenntnis dass ich weiss
es nicht ist klar bank das passiert mir
jetzt besitzen passiert denn ich bin
irgendwie fordern neue situation und
muss miteinander reden aber ich finde
die offenheit sei das fehlen der show
ideal die offenheit sein ich sage ich
sage ich hört sich also die vorstellung
junger solisten versorgt
ja aber das ist glaub ich sehr viel und
so ist das bei dir nicht so wenn jetzt
die mal vorstellen können miteinander
schläft also das war schon etwas hin so
mit denen ich weiß es nicht aber
gar nicht so sehr sexuell sondern von
stärke wenn
es gibt das commitment nehmen und bin
frage ich mich habe ich weiß die polizei
sagt commitment ist genauso toll
und update-service mich immer
entschuldigung aber ich mache den rhein
sind
sie sind verwaist und priorisiert
was hat die unbedingt mit zieht
also
das kannst du nicht entscheidet das rad
einfach passieren das ist nicht zu sehen
natürlich
stand im schnitt
das ist nicht einfach
so mit mit hetero normativität oder mit
dem polo ist doch immer so es sind
einige husumer aber es ist gesellschaft
um sie zum teil sind krasser
unterdrückten nicht sagen sie ist ein
entscheidender spürt man es gar nicht
wenn man sich ihre der darf das gar
nicht fühlen wenn sie interessant die
eigene des bezirks motor an die eigene
ortswehren der fragen die wir im rennen
über die räte sondern überhaupt
liebesverhältnisse dieser vor andre tan
daraufhin die show muss man sich trennen
ich sehe was zum beispiel tv news
schrieb
letzter vorletzte große buch die liebe
endet wo sie seit die negative beträge
und wahnsinnig tour genommen sie
beziehen wo immer evaluiert werden und
im kapitalismus in der kapitalistischen
logik auf oft bessere hier optimiert
werden dass oder chemische immer drauf
gibt es noch ein bessere treffer
unterschied für viele so einfach zu kalt
also du brennst in bildung umwelt
sondern stiege damit noch ein stück
reicher werden und wenn du natürlich
immer nur schwer gehabt die so schnell
denn was sich doch gar mit einem nach
unten ist doch gar keine beziehung
suchen einander tafel mitgliedschaft und
das braucht der schwierige zugang und
miteinander
krisen kürze machen denen zwar insofern
würde ich dir recht also wenn sozusagen
wenn mit dem
und und bezirks früher trennten ein code
einem sehr sehr viele damit genau die ja
die seelenverwandtschaft wo er entsteht
wenn wir lang mit ihm zusammen habt wo
wie hart stellt wir genau und es gab
einen punktestand auf dazu tendieren sie
beziehen zu überleben das ist das
stichwort romantizismus oder roboter aus
begriff braucht also man sollte immer
die schmetterlinge im buch wird immer
der anderen ganz großartig finden aber
natürlich haben dann unterstützen das
als opel partner wenn es darum geht
kinder
und haushalt schmeißen es ist so eine
steigerung und das eigentlich gott
kaspar wirklich leisten sondern bauern
verschiedene schwierigkeiten und bessere
titel so eine these die heimsieben und
freud geehrt und cosic seite wo es
beginnt eskaliert wie und wo man schon
hier betrat nicht begehren aber stimmt
das wirklich
also was nicht geht es da in die studio
das zeigt ich weiß gar nicht empfehlen
wir damit stewardess bravo lang zusammen
sehen
damit ich meine frisch verliebt die hand
über die anden ihr besonders vor und
boden gleich ein
neues kennenlernen sich dass wieder
alles ist so großartig es ist wieder so
viel entdecken
dieselbe
begrenzte andere sachen abonnieren das
darfst du
die standard so die idee von der polizei
beschrieben sie ist mit kommentaren wenn
du nicht wenn du besser aktiviert und
bei der ausstellungs thema findet zu
einer zeit sprechen mit der philosophie
und aggregator über libyen paul emery
und mit dem philosoph alain de botton